Well ebooks or another method of taxed
delivery.
Uh,
and I did run a,
I ran a blog on the subject sometime ago
and it was called three reasons for
keeping paper books and the three
reasons were uh,
solar flares,
which would wipe out communications
towers and not so well any electronic
media that you might happen to have a
stored,
um,
grand overload resulting in brownouts
which would have similar effects and
internet overload and less people are
going to build the grid out more and to
build the net out more.
And there's pretty soon not going to be
very much based on it because of all the
spam and torn,
um,
to the,
to the percentage of 95 I'm told.
So it was very crowded there.
So building out the nat,
building up the grid and what are you
going to do about the solar flare as
well?
I guess a lead lined box is about the
best you can do all of these things.
Point out the fact that electronic
storage is pretty fragile.
If you want to keep something
permanently,
you should probably keep it in paper
form.
And that is why an e version of your
will is not acceptable.
And the reason is it's very hackable and
forageable as I said,
the net is leaky,
uh,
and a number of other legal documents,
which of course drives people crazy
because those paper things take up so
much room.
So it's a problem facing businesses.
What to do with the paper,
why does the alternative to paper,
when can he is a storage,
et cetera.
It's also a problem for people.
For instance,
with small apartments who liked to read,
where are they going to put all the
books?
The ereader gives you portability,
it gives you instant accessibility,
uh,
and it gives you the possibility of
having a whole bunch of books with you
at once on this little device.
So for that it's very,
very handy.
Those are the pluses.
I personally think that it's going to
increase rating because you can acquire
about very quickly,
you don't have to go,
you don't have to wait.
If you could just push the button and
it's there.
If you really like it and want to keep
it,
you may then go get a paper version.
It does remove the element of
serendipity w by which I mean you walk
into a bookstore with the idea of
getting this book and just say three or
four other books that you really feel
you must have,
but you wouldn't have known about them
unless you went into the store.
So how to,
how to create and an e version,
that experience of serendipity,
it's,
it's really hard.
So people are thinking about this.
There's a lot.
The other virtue of the ereader may be
that it's,
but it's helpful for,
um,
kids are having reading problems because
they can isolate blocks of text and make
the letters bigger.